All right, let's get to some of your questions
for the week one that I got a bunch of times,
including during live calls on what day was that?
Live calls on Tuesday was is Donald Trump really
going to run again in twenty, twenty four?
There have already been rumors swirling that
Donald Trump supposedly is telling advisers
he's going to run in 2024. First of all,
we should sort of be skeptical of that, because if
Donald Trump still exists in the state of denial
in which he seems to be living, I don't know that
he still is really believing that it's over. Only
if you believe it's over would you start thinking
about 2024. So maybe he's been saying it. Maybe he
hasn't. I think there's a couple of different ways
to approach this. First of all, I kind of doubt
it. He will be 78, almost 79 at inauguration. That
would make him even older than Joe Biden is now.
Joe Biden, already the oldest president to be
inaugurated into the White House. So I think
in the you know, Trump has what seems to be sort
of adult ADHD. I think that over four years,
Trump's going to a lot's going to happen to Trump
and who knows what he will be doing from four
years from now? I don't find it particularly
likely. Secondly, we really can't control that
right now. There's nothing we can do about that
right now. And so I when the callers ask me this,
I will speculate today. But I am going to go
back to what I was saying. You know, in 2017,
when people ask me about 2020, I would say we
have a midterm here that we have to deal with.
So I think that we should not really worry about
it at this point in time and take the approach of
will deal with that when the time comes. Now, in
terms of what the nominee and even the Republican
primary would look like in 2024, with or without
Trump, we need to see what happens to the
Republican Party in the next two and four years.
And we're going to talk about that next. But there
are lots of names that and remember, in 2012, if
you had asked who's a likely Republican candidate,
you weren't going to hear Donald Trump
from too many people. So I say this
knowing that we're terrible at figuring this stuff
out. But in looking at what are possibilities,
could a child of Trump run in 2020 for Don Jr.
or Ivanka? I think it's less likely with Trump
losing, but it's possible Marco Rubio all of
a sudden seems to be acting as if he's already
running for 20 24 Republican nominee. Tucker
Carlson is being mentioned by a lot of people.
That one's actually scary to me
because I think in today's environment,
Tucker Carlson could actually win a
Republican primary, which is really scary
in four years. I don't know. Right wing extremist
lunatic Tom Cotton's name is being mentioned.
There's always the possibility of a former vice
president running, which would maybe put Mike
Pence in there, although he's so uncharismatic
that it is hard to imagine. But it's within the
realm of possibility. Ted Cruz is a name that
continues to be thrown around and Sean Hannity
calls him one of the greatest legal minds or
something like that. So certainly it's somebody
who would get a boost if the Republican Party
decides to go the direction of a woman. Nikki
Haley comes to mind. Years ago, I would have said,
what about Condoleezza Rice as maybe the first
Republican presidential nominee? I think Condi
Rice, with her disagreements in distance with
Trump ism, is a less likely option for 2024.
But maybe it could be Nikki Haley. Would Jeb
Bush try to sweep back in and say, hey, guys,
let's go back to sanity? My brother was saying
this is what he would say. And I will be saying
and, you know, we can go back to just like boring
evangelical type Republicans. These are all
possibilities. It really is impossible to know
at this point in time. I don't believe it's worth
putting a lot of time into. We have objectives
that are happening right now. The objective in the
immediate is we have just under two months until
there are two Senate runoff elections in Georgia
that will determine who controls the Senate.
That is where 98 percent of our efforts
need to be. The other two percent just on
keeping an eye on Trump and making sure he doesn't
do anything too crazy in these remaining weeks
after that point, it will be a year of what is
Joe Biden's first year pushing for him to get
things done that are possible with a Democratic
Senate if he has it without a Democratic Senate,
if he doesn't have it. And we'll talk
about what those things are momentarily,
we will then go right into the twenty, twenty
two election. And that is going to start before
you know it. We're probably, you know,
10 months from the from the early stages
of twenty, twenty two election. And that if
Democrats don't take control of the Senate this
time, which remains to be seen, taking control
of the Senate in 2022 will be a massive priority.
And in fact, if Democrats don't get the Senate
this time, getting the Senate in 2022 is what
all of Joe Biden's first term successes,
the major successes legis. Successes
could ride on, so that will be massively
important and then when the time comes,
we will get to talking about twenty, twenty
four, but I would not spend more time than is
worth spending on it at this point in time. And
this gets us right into question number two today